well the past year of various Russia
investigations have completely dominated
the business of government in Washington
but there was supposed to be a payoff at
the end we were supposed to find a
sinister plot between Donald Trump and
Vladimir Putin to take over American
democracy but we didn't find that
instead we found that our own
intelligence agencies are in some cases
hotbeds of partisan bias and political
extremism peter Strock lisa page John
Brennan over at CIA choses security
clearance
all of this adds up to the perception
that maybe we shouldn't be vesting this
level of trust in our own intelligence
agencies that's a sad thing what can we
do about it trey gowdy is a congressman
representing South Carolina he's the
chairman of the House Oversight
Committee retiring and he joins us thank
mr. chairman thank you for coming on yes
sir thank you so first just a news of
the day question I watched as the
Speaker of the House Paul Ryan and
senator bob Corker of tennessee both
seem to suggest that john brennan
deserved to have a security clearance
and and I'm confused what possible
benefit to American national security
would be served by letting John Brennan
keep his security clearance the only
theoretical benefit Tucker and I'm just
playing the devil's advocate is if his
successor wanted to discuss a fact
pattern with him having that that level
that security background clearance would
enable that conversation to take place
having said that having a security
clearance is very different from having
access to the documents John Brennan who
by the way said President Trump was
guilty of a crime for which it could be
hanged said he should be in the dustbin
of history I cannot imagine Mike Pompeo
or Gina hospital ever having any reason
to talk to John Brennan and the
president can decide who does and does
not have security clearances what I
can't imagine is how the Speaker of the
House could look at the stories
describing what John Brennan has said in
the past year totally irresponsible and
extreme statements and say you know
that's the man we want to have a
security clearance I don't understand
how you could reach that conclusion
do you only story I saw was that the
pawl fall that
Brennan was being intentionally
provocative that that the president
should just ignore Brennan I have not
spoken to Paul about it but it's not
just Brennan I mean it's also Comey I
mean Comey is telling everyone to vote
Democrat so Bernie Sanders will be the
chairman of the Senate Budget Committee
so how would you like to be investigated
but by this gaggle Brennan Comey struck
page and oh well away there are other
DOJ and FBI officials that haven't been
named because they're not at that that
level they're not the SDS level but they
also had animus towards President Trump
that those are the folks that were in
these dispassionate neutral objective
roles investigating the person who
ultimately became president United
States the American people deserve an
intelligence and a justice system that
is as devoid of politics I get that the
president gets to pick the AG and pick
the FBI director but beyond that facts
are not Republican or Democrat and
neither should our justice system be or
our intelligence community so so very
quickly Democrats on the hill are
enjoying this because it serves their
short-term partisan interests and so
they're abetting it but if you talk
privately any of them who acknowledge
that at some point there's going to be a
Democratic president and is that person
going to be comfortable knowing that the
Intel agencies could turn against him
and destroy his presidency I mean are
they thinking this through at all do you
think yeah they're there plenty of
reasonable folks on both sides of the
aisle they don't always make it on
television yes but I I think one of the
challenges and one of the reasons that
I'm glad to be doing another line of
work home 2019 is the ultimate objective
right now is to win I mean Adam Schiff
says he has evidence of collusion
between the Russians and President Trump
he said it over a year ago he's
presented to absolutely no one there's
no accountability for it they want this
investigation to drag on as long as it
possibly can because it's going to
affect the midterms and they'll get the
gavels in their hand and what I would
hope all of our federal citizens
regardless of whether you're a
Republican or Democrat is just have
higher expectations and demand more from
your elected officials it's not just
about winning it's also by governing in
a responsible way that that's worthy
worthy of people's respect Adam Schiff
accused me of working for Putin he's an
irresponsible buffoon it's it's sad to
watch it actually mr. chairman thank you
very much trial working with a trial
working with a MIDI others I can't even
imagine I can't all right if he goes out
to you thank you